each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
stone this is a an extended an
elaborated version of the presentation
he gave at I WPT apparently where I was
amazed that he got through 52 slides in
25 minutes and that the questioning at
the end demonstrated that people
actually had kept up with them and
really absorbed it so there's quite an
accomplishment Young is a student at
Penn although he's also doing a lot of
collaboration with people at is eye on
things to do with KBS passing and also k
best approaches in general for things
like machine translation and all sorts
of things that are near and dear to our
hands so his schedule is pretty fool for
today with the MSR fellowship interviews
but he's sticking around tomorrow to
talk with additional people just some
sort of sucker for punishment and if
you'd like to sign up with him just talk
to me afterwards I think he was that one
you basically totally guys what this
talk is all about so I have much to say
so this point this work is about cavas
parsing basically meaning fast in the
exact Cape Cape as Victor be passing out
and since I know some of you guys are
working on between translation I also
talk a little about sorry just I'm sorry
about k best translation how to apply
these capers party Agrium's in syntax
based machine translation so first of
all what's kept as parsing well
basically means given a given a lit
match analogous sentence say I saw boy
was a telescope which is ambiguous you
at least got two readings and I not only
wanted first best interpretation but
also the second bath and serve peasant
through the case best so that's the task
of test of getting the top-k
interpretations or our structures for a
given sentence that's k becks parson so
before I talk about any technical
details I first want to convince you
that it's not a easy task for for even
for human beings because my advisor
Irvin do she was when was awarded the
benjamin franklin medal he was asked to
give a talk basically introductory talk
to high school students it was local
Philadelphia kids because the bending
franking Association want the kids to
understand what oh she is doing and what
were like what's natural and processing
what's computing linguistics but that's
really a hard pass to teach the kids but
but to she found a small way to do that
basically just speak a sentence and let
those kids draw whatever they have in
their mind instead of speaking what
instead of telling people what does mean
language because those kids at their age
are much better at visual abilities so
there's actually one kid got this for I
saw her duck
and then the next sentence I you sushi
was tuna the same kid got this so this
is a typical PP attachment problem and
degradation and what can we say well
basically your capers parser is not a
cure there's no reason or no situation
that you can get this interpretation to
be your top interpretation for this
sentence so you didn't prove your Cuba's
parser ok back to technical stuff so so
why is it important from because we
often have NLP as a pipeline of several
stages or several phases say you first
depart to be tagging them parsing and
semantic interpretation and it's often
the case that the first best fun one
stage is not guaranteed to be optimal in
the future phases and what we will do is
to postpone disambiguation by
propagating AK basileus instead of just
propagating a first best answer to the
next phase so that's what people do
between cement between syntactic parsing
and semantic role labeling for example
but it's also true that it's widely used
in discriminative training recent
methods of machine learning especially
in reranking and minimal training or
perception like online learning
basically here we use a Kapus list the
top interpretations to approximate the
whole the full set of all
interpretations which is really
exponentially large say the set of
parses forgiven sentence is
exponentially many right but used but
most of them are crap so just use thick
say top 100 parts to approximate the
whole set and the bed is you get the
majority the the probability mass right
so it's a good approximation so what
people do in previous work well the
simplest and earnest approach attempt to
do that is encoding reranking paper
where he basically turned off dynamic
programming totally meaning no two items
are considered it
traditional are considered equivalent so
that he keeps all the derivations in the
chart which means that is an exponential
algorithm well how to make it work in
practice so he has to do very aggressive
pruning to make it attractive all and
but as we also towards the very end of
this talk this pruning has very bad
effect on the quality of the output so
Chuck Nia and Johnson did something
better recently which is Modi has caused
a fine-grained but it's still not exact
k best but those hours is exact hit que
pasen fast album but it turned out that
there is an earlier a pro earlier paper
which is largely unknown to our
community by two Spanish guys humanism
Marcel which presented basically very
close algorithm to very very much the
same to our final item although about
any improvement and they tested on the
tiny grammar so what our work differs
from their work is that fertile we
formulated our arguments on the very
general framework of directing my tonic
hypergraphs so that all parsing
algorithms that can be captured by this
framework can be up can be applied for
our argument and then we have four
albums for capers items each of which
improving the previous one a little bit
and finally we get albums three which is
pretty fast and we present experiments
on state-of-the-art natural language
systems one on the coding speaker style
parser which is the shebang parser and
the other on the CKY style decoder by
david chan so so first of all what's the
hypergraph when what's it what's the
difference between a hypergraph in the
conventional graph well the only
difference is that in a graph an edge
links two vertices and in a hypergraph a
hyper edge link several vertices to one
vertex and this is very
this is very similar to the deductive
specification of parking areas where you
have antecedent atoms and if you have
derived all these three antigen items
you can derive the consequent item so
this deductive rule is captured as the
hyper rage in hyper graph and so if
you're familiar with CKY this is the
secret deduction and for example you can
have em pvp and you can derive an ounce
this an instantiation with the rule of
the deductive rule and this instantiated
rule is basically a hyper edge where the
items in the chart are vertices in hyper
graph and this deduction is a hyper edge
so this way hyper graph can be sort of
as a compiled version of the
instantiation of deductive special
detective specification of parking
albums so that's what Caroline manage it
for logical deduction and it's also it's
also the same as the notion of pact
forest in our view so for ample distance
I saw boy with telescope there are two
interpretations and how do you compare
lee represent both of them well that
means do you have a message to to use
polynomial space to represent
exponentially many parses right and
that's what hacked forest does basically
combine the two equivalent items
basically because these to be be
spending the same range of industries
and they are go sleepy so they are
equivalent that's the only ambiguous
party in this sentence and that's a pact
forest so so so we all know packed for
us but if what if we just rearrange
these nodes a little bit and then we get
a have a graph so now the nodes are
vertices and these links are hyper
regice so basically it's not not it's
really nothing you so but people also do
in practice weighted reaction like PC
probabilistic context-free grammars or
as such so we also need to formulate
wedge attacking into weighted have
graphs
so well it's also very straightforward
in which direction you have save weight
or the score the best score of the best
derivation of this item B and C n if you
derive the item aik then you know the
resulting weight is the result of
applying the weight function f to the
weights of the enticing items and in
secret way it's really simple just B
times C times probability of this rule
but in general in a way to have a graph
suppose you have a weight a deductive
introduction and you have a weight
function for each deduction then you can
represent it as a hyper rage but you
just have a weight function in this
hyper so so a widget hyper graph has a
set of vertices set of hyper edges a
special dance called target basically
meaning the goal item safe or insecure
White's s of one and basically if you
recognize as for the host energy when
you are done and r is the weight set
where your weights are prime and we were
going to be a total order set so that we
can compare derivations and your hyper
edge is a set of antecedents as tails
and head of the edge that's costco and
in a way to function so if you have the
weight fight for this rule and basically
have the same for this hyper rage so
that's formalizing the net have waited
deductive system but we have graph in
this way it's a little bit more flexible
or general than weight deduction in a
sense that we can have different f
different wave function for different
hyper edges whereas in the width
deductive system all the which functions
are in the same class say a times B
times C times the probability of this
rule so we can have ad hoc weight
functions for ad hoc the ad hoc
instantiation of deduction which is a
little bit more general so any questions
so far
this is no other is Eugenia this can be
more than CFG say you have a tag you can
stew it represent you have a cheer joint
grab a partner because we represent them
as the way to detection system developed
system and any partial angle that can be
captured as a weighted deductive system
can be formulated as a hyper graph
search problem so but Stella Tory will
grab everything underneath in a single
scored that sort of suggests finale so
so this is a very good point so hyper
graph for hyper graph you can represent
as a CFG but this C of G is different
from the original gramercy because you
intersect the CFG with which the
sentence basically with the DFA
representing the sentence so that's the
exactly the same as the bacalao
intersection approach where you
intersect the CFG was a DFA then you get
still get a CFG because safety
interacted with regular grammar is still
CFG and the parsing is can be viewed as
the generation problem in that
intersected CFG so there's two different
safety pup will say yeah I'm sure you're
going to get to this in a minute but at
this point what I'm wondering is what
what score do you put on a hypergraph if
you have oh I guess it is yeah what
score do you associate that with a that
with a node if there are two different
hyper edges that have that notice their
target yeah as you take the best of them
it takes me see ya who's the Derby yeah
years of it by I'll cover that in its
our slides
there might be other applications where
you want to take some yeah I exactly so
so so so the yeah so here we only care
about comparison basically take it
better but you say marine if we can have
this some operator which you can take
the inside for level right so here we
only care about the optimization problem
so we have the total order set so okay
so so we talk about the weight function
a lot and we have a very critical assume
that all the weight functions are all
framework must be monotonic on each of
their arguments what does that mean for
every in secret why f which function is
B times C times the probability of this
rule and this is of course monotonic on
pnc argument but in general this
requirement formalizes the optimal
subprime property in dynamic programming
that is if you want a pride I
improvement you have to have the optimal
time property that means if you can
decompose a large problem a into B and C
sub promised BNC and you and if you have
something better for the sub B so you
have a B prime which is better than the
original solution then by applying the
monotonic weight function f you can
always get something better for a as
well in other words if you claim
something if you claim this is the best
solution for a then the solution for pnc
must also be the best for the subprimes
as well so that's the album supper
property
now as we have hypergraphs another
capers problem now very easy just
basically find the top creations of the
target vertex t insecurity is very easy
another critical assumption is that we
only care about a cyclic hypergraphs so
that we can have a topological sort of
among the vertices and we just proceed
along the topological ordering we know
that CKY of course is a cyclic and a lot
of the parking atoms are RFA circling so
now we come to algorithms so we have
four atoms from naive 222 lazy but
before I talk about nek best algorithm I
first want to have some basic idea of
generic first best Viterbi algorithm so
so so we call it too generic Viterbi
Alan but it's physically extending the
origin Viterbi on the hypergraph so
basically you have a topological sort
first you at the bottom sword on the
hypergraph and then proceed in the
topology ordering basically for each
vertex for each increment hyperedge you
take the result of this hyperedge using
the weights of the enticing items f
anything ay ay ay and B are the weights
of U and W just to remind the intuition
behind it you think about CKY these u
and v and u GVWR items in charge so if
you have another hyperedge you take
better this that's what valve set and
you have more it take a bit better
dictate the best of all these results of
all these high bridges and that's the
linear and that's the complexity linear
in the number of hybrids because you
visit each highbridge wise and only wise
and as a special case CKY for chomsky
normal form is cubic times number
product and this number is exactly the
number of hyper edges in the hypergraph
and that's why it's equal ice cube so
secure I being a special instance of the
generic with first class with turbulent
so well that's really nothing you
because dynamic programming has been
around for more than 50 years so what I
presented before is really nothing new
but but what these guys the inventors of
dying from doesn't know is K best
dynamic programming algorithms well the
easiest approach that extending the
first best Viterbi 2k best is simply
replaced vector we replaced of weight a
and B to be a vector of K guys and if
you maintain them to be sorted then a
one will represent the first they're the
best derivation of the best wait for a
and a cave the case best there is
derivation waiting for eight okay so now
a SMBs are both lens k now the question
is what's the result of applying the
weight function f to these two vectors
well which function is not defined that
way because we're watching is defined
only on two numbers now you have two
vectors well if you have two two vectors
and all the possible ai and BJ is a
possible solution is possible element
fought when applying f2a a SMBs so
basically you have k square
possibilities and then you want to
select the top k among them because if
you only work you're only interested in
the K Paz derivation of the top leaders
in for this V so you don't need all the
K squared guys right so basically you
enumerate all the K square guys first
and then do sorting or selection
basically to get the top K so that's
what we say multi k equal top here all
day I bj right okay so that means you
have at least k square amount of work to
do but that's not not not not at all
because when you have another hydrogen
coming then you basically want to take
the bed of these two but now you have k
guys here ok guys here
and let this step is you the easier
because you know this k guys are sorted
and this cake is also solid so just take
the top k among the 2k guys that's
linear that you can do a merge sort like
saying which is linear but simply
computing the multi k is k squared so
this is no good no better than k square
so that you have that means you have a k
square overhead for each hyper reg right
so your overall complexity is k square
times e this is really bad because in
practice you want 2k to be very large
say a silent for translation or if it's
our new roommate one 10,000 foot parsing
me on 100 so it means this k square will
kill you your questions so we can do
something slightly better because the
worst thing about the previous album is
your numerator k squared guys first but
you really don't want don't need to do
that because you only need the top k
guys and remember that ace and bees are
sorted and the void function f is
monotonic that means a1 b1 must be the
best of all these k squared guys right
and then what about the second best well
it must be either a 1 B 2 or a2 b1 it
cannot be anything else right and then
what about a third best so so here is
the devil so you have four guys for a
four guys will be you know that this guy
a 0 a 1 B 1 must be the first task and
the second person must be either these
two guys and since 24 is better than 20
you know this guy's to the second best
and what about service well it must be
come on these three guys basically have
a frontier of candidates for the next
best and each iteration you take the
best of these candidates and then
replace it with the two shoulders or
successors which right now this all
right so it's oh yeah there's a better
way to do that so you say ok when I
replace the 24 I only actually need to
replace with the 18 right a 16 right but
but that that requires a little bit more
work a little bit more I mean
improvement but but the the the general
way is just just replace just replace it
with the two shoulders you mean you are
guaranteed to get best not to you
although your way is it's like a little
bit better but a actually improves the
it costs a little bit but a lot of
complexity so it's very good point yes
now the surpassed is 20 and you replace
it with the top to the two shooters and
now 16 is already in the people we don't
push it again you just push the 215 so
you basically keep a heap or priority
queue or whatever project you would like
to do to maintain the candidates so this
way it's que la que because you only
need k adorations each other you pop one
guy and you can stop when you find the
case best value only you don't even need
to what I what's here what's here you
don't even calculate them
and you need dark a to maintain the
hippie in each adoration so it's kayla
ok for each hyperedge so the conclusion
you keep Franco which one's your pop-pop
you it's only fair right Lee what do you
mean you hope you don't the only pop up
there so you keep track of the one that
you pop up in each list and the only
comparison the head of the list each
time yeah but you need to first of all
you need to extract the best of the heap
this is just like you merge to sort of
listen no no so this in this candidate
is not sorted yeah you just met in a
heap of priority queue and get the top
one is lock a time so so that's a good
excuse so Stu not the best because we're
doing a lot of waste of work because we
calculated in the previous and one we
calculate the top-k from each hyper edge
right but we really what we really need
is the top K for this vertex at the end
okay you just you don't even need to
know all these k guys if you just can't
get the top k for this vertex than your
you're good so instead of doing them
sequentially each can we do them
simultaneously so of course by the same
same yeah you now you know that for
ample this vertex has three hyper edges
any sharper edge you know there's a
square as before now you know that the
first pass of this V must be one of the
first best of each hyperedge right so
here k is to the meaning you're owning
top 2 and d is the degree or incoming
degree for this vertex V so d is three
in the case when d is larger than k you
can throw away the useless hyper edges
so here the study to the worst of these
three guys is never going to be used in
in the top two candidates because so we
know that among these three guys this is
the this is the third so this guy has no
to get into one of these two slots and
all these guys in this square are no
better than this guy or worse than this
guy so if this guy has no chance and all
this square has no chance at all so just
deleted now you have two guys right you
know that this 42 is the best and what's
the second pass well as before it's
among these three guys basically
replaces with the two shoulders but now
you have an item level keep you have a
kind of more global heap instead of a
pepperidge specifically and used to do
the same thing like extractor fasting
helps you and now you have the second
place okay now you are done then you
only you don't even need to worry about
all these guys you didn't calculate them
so this improves a lot a significantly
from the the previous item but still not
perfect because we're still calculating
the top k translate the top k divisions
for each vertex but at the end of the
day we only need the top kitchen top
grade divisions for the target vertex
right so why bother to calculate to to
waste time for intermediate vertices so
so take a step further and you notice
that the progression from Evelyn zero
toggle to the central theme is that we
delay the calculations until and to
really need it that means we are lazier
and lazier that's really kind of on
demand computation and we have larger
locality that in 10 we look at each
hyper rage at a time album to we look at
all hyper ages in coming to one vertex
and in Adams three we look at the whole
hyper hyper graph at a time so okay 730
lazy offline aaron has two phases the
first phase is forward basically to a
normal first batch search till the final
item and this is nothing different or
very similar to the first best Viterbi
algorithm one thing different is we
construct a hypergraph of packed forests
along the way I mean in conventional
Viterbi a first basket or you don't need
to to keep track of the
the non optimal have back pointers you
basically keep the best back pointer for
each item right and control with all the
alternative back pointers but now in
order to recover the second base or
whatever you need to store the
alternative hyper edges to each vertex
but time complexity wise is the same
because you visit these hybrids anywhere
and reclusive backhoe if they start by
asking the final item what's your second
best and if I cannot decide at this time
because it has to ask his parents in
basically propagating the question 2 to
the grandparents and blah blah to the
leaves and then once you get a second
westerner you ask what's your second
server best so so here's the demo so s17
is either satisfy no vertex or target
and has three hyper edges and in in the
first best face you know this hyper it
is the first best ok that lets you
already know now k is 2 and d is three
you you can as well just throw this the
worst hyperize event basically nothing
here you're gonna make a slot into these
two slabs now you start by asking the
question what's your second best well so
basically it's either this one or the
second best among along this hyper rage
right so so or the same same as asking
what's your successor on this hyper
hyper graph well it must be either these
two guys as before so you know that my
second-best must be among these three
guys just as the same as in Adam too but
question sorry yeah but the critical
question the crucial point is you don't
know these two guys yet because in the
first best face you only know the first
best of each item that's the difference
found a little too I don't choose
forward so you know everything now what
can you do wait well because I don't
know the second best of empty ones three
then I basically asked the same question
to my parent as well right so I ask
what's your second dress to these three
these two guys and they will propagate
this question to leave so so so Meghan
some time but I don't see how this is
different from a Star Search okay great
so so in speech road people do this
backward in our fold for the top to top
K generations right but in the
difference between speech world in our
parking mode is that the speech world is
largely finite state so the intended
line structure is a graph instead of
hyper graph and now because we're doing
parsing your syntax of a translation we
have hyper graph where you can combine
or basically an end or graph basic we
can combine two verges it's not like one
vertex and point to in other words
several vertex point to work one vertex
so you have a problem of combination
which is here like a square so that you
combine a I and BJ that's not in the
speech one it's not into a star I don't
think
up so so when you do the forward
backward pass when you do invest
extraction using a star algorithm
anywhere enjoyment is right you have
forward pass one best you have a
backward pass one bit actually I you
just do the backward pass on this and
that gives you the optimal continuation
from every point to the end of the again
the graph and then when I when I started
asking okay so what is the next best you
have all those partial hypothesis in the
stock much what you have here and then I
say okay we'll give me the next one yeah
I really maybe we can take it offline
but yeah it seems a little better soon
yeah the idea is similar basically we
are extending it to to to the world of
hyper graph where you I mean basically
you have combinations which I mean it's
not in the case of here what each
combination is a hypothesis there's
going to be in this time these are
well that means you transform the
hypergraph into a conventional graph in
the end before he'll I mean hypothesis
can just be a hybrid run yeah maybe we
can take it off mine okay so it's now
recursion goes up to leave that by
propagating the same question what sauce
I confessed and then they were basically
backward reporting numbers of second
best to to these two items and now you
know the second best of like now you
know basically you know all these three
candidates and now you can say okay this
is my second dress and if you want more
than cast more what's your service so
this is the idea of a grocery so so
here's there is an alternative
implementation and suggested by Jason is
now basically in the forward phase I as
I said info face you have to keep all
the hyper edges you have to control the
whole hardware but sometimes your search
space you'll have a graph is too large
that's specially for translation for
example then your memory is not
sufficient to do that but we can we can
do something clever we can only keep the
best highbridge as in the normal one
best Viterbi but the backward face
recover all the other high bridges on
the fly so when you ask this final item
what's your second best and it only has
the best hyper edges pepperidge but it
can recover the alternative approaches
although this is really a waste of time
because you already visited this hyper
edges in the forward phase you basically
doing it again basically it's trading
time for space so you and then ask this
one and trim recover hyper it all hyper
edges okay so here's a summary of time
complexity of these items we start from
a first pass item which is linear in the
number of hyper edges and then naive
algun is created k to the a where a is
the area in CKY is too because we're
binary i am doing binary
and I've been one how improved it to
kill lk let's do multiplicative overhead
acumen to is a dramatic improve because
it improves the market colligative
o'hare to an edited form right and agnes
three-wheeler mean vocabulary of the
sentence no sorry v means the word
number of the vertices yeah basically
it's how many items we have in the child
so number of non-terminals times n
square because you have to India's very
like BP 17 and he is number hyper edges
and D is the size of derivation
basically how many notes you have in the
tree in the departure its linear in the
end because if you have a sentence of
any words then we have the trees also
sides of sites linear 2n albums three
improved from admin to basically by
changing this B to D and D is really
really small like linear in this is
cubic so in practice this II really
dominates that means as long as you
don't have very well or until you have
very large k your the complexity is
still not much different from a single
message which order e so in localities
from hyper edge to the goebel hyper
graph for off us for all these items so
so if i look at algorithm to pursue
sound room 322 vs 3 so it still
dominates and yeah 3 yeah it's only the
overhead this part because this you
cannot do anything about it even in
first best you have to do this anyway
right so this is a kind of inherent in
in the problem you cannot improve in it
so it's still time it's to compare of
course because we're doing something
more we're doing k best partying
partying is cubic when we're doin k
becks party would basically want to
minimize the overhead we cannot improve
the the party as hell so so that's that
you have that our objectives only to
make like computing the top solid part
is not much different from canoeing the
first pass cars so that's what be
showing the experiments so we have two
experiments so in the forward pass are
you still Stewart only the papist hyper
edges for each node oh you mean agnes
three yes we store because we only need
the k top k we only start the top k
hyper edges although we can store all
the hyper edges then that need to
generalize J&J and I will which is a
little bit different a little bit slower
than ours but it's not much slower you
can store all hyper edges and so is the
K locate come in because that's the cost
of keeping
right yeah all the key lock you can say
anything because the assertion idea and
now all these items are very similar
just making a people so what was what
what's little D oh D is the degree of
incoming degree that's how many high
bridges do you have basically yeah so in
case where D is a very much larger than
k then then we have much better the
generalized feminism asylum so
experiments so first the coatings Pakal
parser on the penn treebank so we
implemented our item 0 1 and 3 on top of
the p.o parser and recall the average
wall clock time for per sentence on
section 23 so so here the x axis is k so
this means like computing the top top
sound horses and this is time so so we
see that I can and this is not secure by
the way so so 3 is much much faster than
one- much faster than 0 and 3 to nearly
kind of stayed the same because the
complex is e + D Calaca where e
dominates the time for computing the
first best part is nearly most of work
here that means we have very little
overhead computing the second master
best fourth-best till the reason you
didn't run too because yeah because big
to is intermediate and use a lot of
memory and memory wise to choose is bad
actually actually we didn't I I made a
slide of space complexity complex
comparison actually Adam Street is more
space efficient than a balloon one
because I will take it up later what is
the average sentence length there I
already silence last it's like 23 in
achievement 23 world 20 22 23 words each
second chemistry least like a disturbing
from 1 265 the maximal a statistic
happen most of sentences are less than
40 words long so so besides efficiency
we also about accuracy because our
search is more efficient we can use less
pruning and the quality of the output
will be little bit better than the naive
message that's all hope so so we compare
our curry ranking results to measure the
quality of our output so what I just
talked about what's our query ranking
basically if you have a first best for
one sentence and compared to going on
standing the tree bank it might be like
eighty-nine percent accurate and if we
relax it to the top pay parses in the
article that the best maybe 96 and you
also get something very bad so article
ranking meaning pick the best parts
according to go to standard is kind of
cheating because in real rank you don't
have to access to the golden standard
you basically just just compare these
guys and pick one say maybe this guy and
so so but I'll Korea also make sense
because it's the upper bound of any
reroute be ranking system and also if
you get good for good ranking then you
have the potential to get good real
ranking below so this is the article
ranking curve we compare ours our curve
is this line and compared to chatting
Johnson we this the dots and this is
colleen's to sound ranking paper and
this is random car keys earlier passer
so so acts all above us because
they start from a different parser where
the first pass of China party is already
1.5% one point five percent higher
Coney's parser so it's really a lot of
good compared so the real comparison
between hours in the coatings because
they are based on the same car sir so if
we see that as K goes larger all curves
do still improve that means we can get
better and better from from larger
larger cave as lists the corniest curve
converges at around 50 and the reason is
explained in this slide so so another
flood is done by by by join the average
number of passes for census of given
center given land for example this this
guy is so this point it means on average
how many parts do you get for sentence
of Saudi words long okay so interior is
speaking and soon as it gets longer you
get more and more parties actually
exponentially more parties and the
sentence it goes longer right then why
this coatings curve actually drops off
after like 40 so so you should go go go
higher and basically a bell curve it
goes higher and we have a keg or Hydra
so you cannot cannot exceed this ceiling
so the reason why I Coons is like this
is because he has the very aggressive
funi in the first slide the what he did
is a heart beam with and I'm sorry a
hard sell sell limit that is only at
most 100 items can be English in a chart
sale hsl meaning meaning all times with
the same span so all MP or vp from one
to seven
so that way if he proves a lot of
potentially good horses and added every
day he has difficulty recovering a parse
becoming a good at parts and in some
extreme cases where she is extremely
long like 40 were 60 words you cannot
recover any part at all that means get
low parts so that's 0 so I think
historically people used to important
precision and recall on sentences when
requested for the big lens right yeah so
they could explain see exactly so so
yeah that's correct so so this part of
the corpus is only seven percent so
Coney Scott the majority right which are
you not I mean not as good as ours but
not too bad and if you see very short
sentence always less less than 10 words
these two curves actually match exactly
well very well right that means for
short sentences because the the pruning
it doesn't doesn't do that much wrong so
so ok it's good but as soon as get
longer longer the front effect becomes
more apparent would be interesting if
you plotted just below your distribution
function pejorative distribution on
sentence might just to see how much work
was yeah I exactly very interesting idea
yeah so the majority of the corpus of
the penn treebank will lie between trend
between 20 and 30 words on yeah
but-but-but list also suggests that
coningsby ranking results did worse on
very long sentences but yeah so so his
lesson 40 words result is much better
than the whole
so now we shift to machine translation
so so here is our so here David chan
implement these albums on the highroad
decoder Adam to industry and this is the
average decoding time excluding the
first best part which is the dominating
part so these two curves also i mean
reconfirm our pricing result but which
is more interesting is how do you use k
best translation is a machine
translation so there at least two
applications for example in high road
system David uses a hundred best
translations basically to tune feature
weights because he has a log-linear
weight model say language model
translation model s parody blah blah
blah let's say 10 features and how did
he how does he tuned the weights and
uses the minimum error tuning or max
blue Cheney vibrant by Franz och which
requires a que best output so that
that's one application and the other is
in the ice ice in tax base translation
system where I worked for the summer for
the past summer for internship so so
their way is so their problem is they
have difficulty integrating the Engram
models in the search in the decoding
part so when easier approach is to just
do the decoding which translation model
only and they they get say live forever
output 25 sound best translations using
our angular and then restoring re-rank
these 25 sound translations with a
tracker model so this helps a lot so
their baseline translation model only
decoding is training 4.4
there's no length model at all just
translation model as the since the
evaluation metric is blue if you don't
have anger models to smooth the output
you get really miserable output if you
do a check on we're ranking on the 25
best translations you suddenly get a ten
percent of 10 rue points crew that's
great you can open but still this is not
perfect because you prune away some
potentially good translations during
this search this this stage of search so
that later on although you have so many
translations none of them is it's good
then you don't you don't have a way to
recover using Chaco Murray ranking so
the better way to do it is to integrate
angra models in the search which so what
is the Oracle there oh yeah we don't
have our ago sorry oh yeah yeah yeah
this is a very good question we I don't
know the the result of their Oracle
which I would guess some 40 awesome I
don't ever don't really know their
number so you just 40 I I cannot it's
true
I can't just you can't do it a sense of
the time because it gives zeros it's
really messy
christmas has been trying some
approximation c square so so if you
integrate the anger model checker model
using a so so so here's something that's
not actually in this talk which I mean
is if you guys interesting talking to me
out how's that how do you integrate
angle models in Justin tax base
translation system which is also very
difficult for for Chris quark system
here so the naive binarization way
because you have to use the CKY decoding
the secured party animal so you have to
do you binarize the grammar into some
manner of binary form now you've
binarization we got this which is better
than chocolate ranking and what I did in
I is synchronous binarization with chaim
then you get 38.4 if you compare to
forensics implementation at ISI so
that's what I site submitted for the
initial evaluation energy that's
alignment temperature temple approach
that's 37 so then use the single so so
is this before the bed between Daniel
Marcou and France oh yeah that's what
you'll often yeah suits yeah exactly so
so so in this evaluation the main entry
i lied i sighs made it is this number is
this this alignment average approach
then there there child their sin tax
system is like this when when the nice
diversion and this is these results are
before this is where do the glass summer
you know this past summers happy hour
which is after the mysteries oh yeah
also that's prizes
sister they left behind and I side now
is this is a google yeah exactly so this
is the last update where he left it did
the stage when he left I sigh so the
wrong t-shirts yeah yeah I exactly so
yeah so that means in two hundred
billion words a target language training
that is worth more than a oh yeah he's
re thank you guys yeah I mean if you
have the same amount of choices then
we'd be friends awesome but it's that
okay so yeah this is the the current my
current research so okay so to wrap up
we first formulate a monotonic
hypergraph formation which is very
general and define a capacitor vision
problem and because the framework is
general then we can make it wider
applicability a lot of promise say it's
in tax based mt and we have que pasol in
which the last one the final album is
pretty fast and our experiments show
that not only the efficiency has been
improved but also because you can do it
more effective search your accuracy it's
also improved so
for a little bit of future work so all
this talk is about k best Viterbi item
where you proceed along fixed ordering
fix a cyclic ordering but we can also do
Cape as a star which say for them put
Dan Klein has a star parser and we can
make it AK passed a star parser and this
is also very this is of great interest
in the machine translation community
because I know some people are already
trying to do k best a star decoding for
machine translation now that's not not a
stock a bath a stop but they doing a
start decoding it for machine
translation for the syntax Space Systems
hope you have done a star de Kooning for
free space system with that as I said
that's basically finite-state world
which is a graph but a start for for
syntax faced the over for the tree road
is is based on high program so that's
little bit different and we are
formalizing dynamic programming the
optimization part into the hyper graph
search problem because we have the
monotonic which functions which is which
is saying the optimal subprime property
in dynamic program and we have to do
real reranking to show that whether this
article improvement repays offing real
be ranking so so China yakking is the
category infra many islands three and
they are also doing ranking which logic
a basically because now you have very
very you have say Assad translations
then you cannot use the like Max entropy
rank you have to use an online rear
anchor say perceptron I below so
otherwise your memory isn't efficient as
it isn't sufficient okay so that's
basically
inhibitions that people well I think
people might prove you more and the
discussion upwards and over here line up
to nitrogen so
sweets implementation
most report I am essentially trees
I suppose so it's meant to be like she
sighed and that's from the end of this
book from you a free tract I told them
that it be finished earlier increase the
probability of taking somewhere
interesting right so we have to be back
by what